okay just kind of needs to look right
here men in black international trailer
came out and this was honestly already a
movie that I was looking for do on
premise alone first of all I love the
original man in black I think it's a
really phenomenal piece of work and
frustratingly was built in a way that
really did lend itself to a franchise
but they completely committed what I
consider to be one of the worst sequel
sins you can do which is to hit the
reset button in order to force things in
the sequel to be the same as they were
in the first one even though the entire
ending premise of the first one kind of
demanded that things be at least
slightly different next time and they
just refuse to do that for two sequels
but we've got a new director new writing
team new stars and I'm not saying I'm
not gonna miss Will Smith I'm not I will
say I won't miss Tommy Lee Jones not
because he wasn't good in the part even
in the later films but because that
character's story was complete at the
end of the first movie so no I won't
miss him I will miss Will Smith a little
bit I wouldn't be surprised if he'd
cameos in there somewhere but you know
I'll miss him a little bit but getting
Tessa Thompson Chris Hemsworth Emma
Thompson back because she was in the
third one I don't know how many people
remember that how many people saw the
third one I did it was okay that was
better than the second one anyway but
okay so just doing this world honestly I
got a little bit of a oh just hearing
even the hints of that Danny Elfman
theme
then it would kind of fader did you do
am i oh god I've missed it like to the
point that getting those feelings
invoked by this trailer made me realize
I missed this a lot more than I would
have thought and I just I just love
everything that I see now what I see is
not a lot of plot which is standard for
an initial trailer it's giving you the
premise at least of both Tessa Thompson
and Chris Hemsworth character Chris
as is already with the bureau he's not
the old JT guy that Tommy Lee Jones is
character was and Tessa Thompson is the
newbie more to the point she's the
newbie who found them out on her own
which i think is an interesting kind of
twist it's similar to Will Smith's thing
but a little bit different which I like
and just the vibe feels good I like that
Tessa Thompson is coming in very
utilitarian whereas Chris Hemsworth
seems to be possibly a little lazy but
also seems to be trying to do it a bit
by the book there's some great like I
love the the side view mirror rolling
back in all the guns I will say there
were a lot of guns and I don't have a
problem with like high-tech sci-fi
weaponry I'm really kind of hoping we'll
get a lot of you know tech that isn't
guns because I feel like that that's an
area that the first film did well
because you have a bunch of random I
mean the neuralyzer is not random its
plot central but you've got a bunch of
random stuff like that little ball that
will spin to touches and it just zooms
all over the place and you know things
like that I am I want to see more like
that and there was a lot of emphasis on
just the weaponry in this trailer that's
not necessarily indicative of anything
but it is kind of a little bit of I hope
they get as inventive with everything
else now I'm recording this having watch
the trailer and having enjoyed the
trailer and I don't I have not looked at
reaction online so I don't know if we're
dealing with a bunch of accusations of
oh they made it all you know liberal and
agenda pushing because now we have a
black woman on the team or what-have-you
I really hope not because you know the
the makeup of the MIB as an organization
has always had a decent diversity
especially yeah me even in the very
first film which was mostly men on there
but at the very end we saw the female
character who we knew became an agent so
obviously there were women agents here
obviously there are black agents Will
Smith hello so I really hope that
people's understanding of the baked-in
inherent nature of this group especially
if they're now going international and
going beyond just
New York which is what the original
three films were always confined to I
really hope that no one's throwing that
kind of stuff at it I'm just gonna
acknowledge it here because on the off
chance that it is happening like
justjust I'm I just hope it isn't let's
go with that
so coming back to everything yeah I like
the energy I like to feel I like the
vibe I like the look I like that we see
the worm guys I'm hoping that older
alien nods like that will be in that
same vein they will be like hey and then
gone I don't want them to dwell on them
a whole lot like again that was
something that the sequels to the first
one kept 'miss doing because what was so
great about that first film is it felt
like a glimpse into this massive world
where all there could be who knows
what's in there and then the sequels
that kept bringing back the same thing
they kept bringing back Frank the plug
and the worm guys and you know so it it
really the sequels Shrunk the world back
down and just by the title International
I'm hoping we are opening the world up
more and that's really what I want to
see from this I won't if this is what I
want it to be even though it is in no
way canonically resetting the franchise
in my mind if this is good then this is
the immediate sequel to the original men
in black that that's if it's good if
it's just fine which I mean it might be
I I won't be surprised this turns out
bad like there's enough that I see here
going in and it's got the vibe just
right like I will be shocked if this is
bad but if it's just fine then I'll
probably just go back to thinking
there's only one men in black films so I
suppose worst case scenario at least in
my mind what I think is worst case based
off what I'm seeing it's a no harm no
foul situation franchise was already in
a bit of a state so there you go many
black international using the trailer
what do you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drops ending down in the
comments let's talk about a whole bunch
of stuff down there if I've done my
stuff right there should be actually
merch options down there or out and then
there's the of course the description
below that will link to the patreon
which if you're feeling generous that'd
be awesome
other links besides that pio bars etc
check it out if you want to and if you
don't that's okay too cuz at the end of
the day you are the council and I just
run the meetings until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]